[Music]
it's a good job that Harry and Megan's
new home is tucked away in a quieter
corner on the Windsor State as noisy
rendition of congratulations rang out
just 24 hours after their son was born
inside the castle a little boy's
great-grandparents were hosting a lunch
we haven't seen Prince Phillip in public
for months but his new great grandchild
was the big topic of conversation back
in London at a sailing event the Duke
and Duchess of Cambridge as experienced
parents were clearly excited to be an
uncle and aunt obviously thrilled I was
thrilled and looking forward to seeing
them in the next few days
is one that I'm very pleased and glads
welcome my brother to the sleep
deprivation society that is parenting
the next few weeks it's a bit daunting
even on an important diplomatic trip to
Germany Prince Charles was picking up
baby gifts from the president and saying
that he was delighted to be a grandad
again
ever since Prince Harry revealed that
they'd had a boy the eyes of the world
have been on Windsor everyone wanting to
hear more about their new arrival Harry
and Megan have tightly controlled all of
the details that been released so far
about their new son but it hasn't
stopped the speculation about where
exactly he was born with some
suggestions that Megan may not have had
the home birth that she'd hoped for and
instead may have ended up in a hospital
but the palace won't confirm any of that
simply saying now that that remains
private still thinking about names on
its the babies a little bit overdue so
we've had a little bit of time to think
about it they still haven't announced a
name but whether they go for traditional
or modern every parent will understand
the pressure to get it right I think
they've got a lot more pressure than we
have they've got a lot of history behind
them and royal traditions I do have
sympathy with Harry and Megan trying to
choose a baby name particularly in their
position and tomorrow will be a big day
for the newest member of the royal
family with a small photo opportunity a
chance for the world to see their new
son for the very first time Rhiannon
Mills and Sky News in Windsor
[Music]
you